we are approaching the vertical design
Phase 2 which will have the Lander
module hovering at nearly 150 meters
above the lunar surface
[Applause]
the sensors that are updating at this
point are providing confirmation of the
safety of the landing site
as expected the retargeting is going on
and this is a very good signature for
the Lander
away
currently only two engines are now being
fired
and we are nearly at zero velocity
vertical and horizontal we are we were
hovering and now we are approaching the
moon surface
okay
[Music]
we can see the honorable Prime Minister
srinarendra Modi ji who is here to
encourage us
and he is critically looking at the
visuals
[Applause]
people are applauding
from the secretary Department of space
and chairman ISRO SRI l somnath
Lander model
safely or softly yeah
[Applause]
the hard work of the entire istro
Community has come to fruition
[Applause]
sir we have achieved soft landing on the
moon India is on the moon
sir
I request
I request our honorable prime minister
to address us and bless us thank you sir
foreign
there we have it India has done
something that no other country has been
able to do not the United States of
America not Russia not China they have
successfully put a Lander on the South
Pole of the Moon a massive moment for
the Indian space research organization
as we see Narendra Modi uh speaking to
the mission control room uh who he's
been monitoring from the brick Summit in
South Africa and a huge round of
applause broke out huge cheers for when
the moment happened where India the
first ever Nation to successfully land
on the South Pole of the Moon well
Christopher uh consulate a professor of
extra Galactic astronomy at the
University of Manchester has also been
watching on
um first of all Christopher what do you
make how big a moment is this for space
exploration
Road
it's a huge moment so all the
congratulations to the Indian Space
Agency for for doing this this is a
remarkable thing and as you said it's
something that hasn't really been done
before of course other countries have
been to the moon but not to this
location on the moon where there's a lot
of interesting science and a lot of
interesting discoveries that could be
made and so India should very much audit
for this can you just explain uh to us
what sort of discoveries are they hoping
to make here I know there's been talk
that there might be potentially frozen
water in this part of the moon what
would that mean if they were to discover
frozen water there
so
a couple of things that are interesting
about that so if you have water it has a
lot of potentials for not only just
science but also for things about you
know colonizing the moon for using the
moon as a as a resource because water is
very important not just for for life but
for for doing any kind of activities uh
it could be very useful so there's that
but also this the south south end of the
Moon the South Pole of the moon is very
very dark and it's very cold it's
negative 240 Celsius so it's very cold
and so it really kind of throws in the
formation of the solar system at that
time because not much has been happening
at that part of the Moon uh since the
moon was formed five billion years ago
or so and so if you can study the
properties of the moon at that location
study what's in the brown study what's
in the atmosphere study the seismic
activity that that has happened and that
is it is is happening and you can learn
quite a bit about the formation of the
the moon but also the formation of the
entire solar system and so since this
location is so on
on
mess with in a sense then it has the the
secrets of of the the past and so this
is one of the main reasons why why it's
it's gone there and what would it mean I
know there's been a lot of talk about
the missions to Mars uh over the next uh
decade or so what would it mean uh for
that
so the more we understand about the moon
the more we're going to understand about
the solar system and so Mars is
obviously the next step in that process
and so if we can figure out something
about the moon about how its atmosphere
Works about how its structure was formed
then we'll know a little bit more about
perhaps how it has happened on Mars and
then when we go to Mars we'll have much
more information about what to expect
and about what kind of thing you might
find there and it all Builds on each
other and so by knowing about the moon
we can learn about Mars and about and
also the Earth in some ways although the
Earth is much more geologically active
in the moon of course but we're just
learning more and more about it and
it'll tell us a lot more about Mars and
what we can expect to find and what what
we might want to search for once we get
to Mars to understand it even better
[Music]
now the the Vikram Lander has uh has has
made it to the surface of the Moon
intact you know once the dust settles
there what is the next step I understand
there's a Rover on board and that's
going to be a big part about doing
scientific experiments and getting it
back to uh back to worth and finding out
a little bit more can you just take us
through the next I guess week or so uh
what will be done there
right so uh the timeline will depend
somewhat on on uh tests and various uh
Communications that that that the Indian
space agency will do with with the
Lander and the Rover but once everything
looks stable then the Rover will be
dispatched in the experiments uh uh will
occur and those will happen uh for some
time I'm not exactly sure for how long
those experiments will go on but I
mentioned it'll be for um a bit of time
and I know the landing date has been
very carefully selected to coincide with
the start of a lunar day can you just
explain to the layperson like myself
exactly what that entails and why that
is so important
right so the the the the lunar day is
basically it's an equivalent to the way
that we have a day where basically the
the um uh uh the moon goes around the
earth which produces this uh this this
uh a parent day on the moon and you you
want to be able to do things at certain
things Christopher we're just going to
listen into Narendra Modi now
um
[Music]
in Beach
the world is witnessing
India G20 presidency
our approach of
one Earth
one family
one future
is resonating
across the globe
this human Centric approach
that we present
and that we represent
has been
welcome
universally
our moon mission
is also based on the same human Centric
approach
therefore
this success
belongs to
all of humanity
and it will help
Moon missions
by other countries in the future
I am confident
that all countries in the world
including
those from the global South
are capable of achieving such fits
we can all aspire
for the moon and Beyond
Maha Beyond
say again
hum
are song okay if you are just joining us
that is the Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi who has been monitoring
developments from The brics Summit in
South Africa after the Indian space
research organization successfully the
first successful Mission ever to land a
lunar lander on the South Pole